i'm very pleased to say that the
environment secretary george houston
joins us in the studio minister lovely
to see you this morning um
i suppose one has to ask after what we
were hearing in in james report there
how concerned
is the british government about the
behavior of the u.s president right now
well look um we think that uh the the
statistics are very clear that joe biden
has won that's what uh the the position
is
but it's um this is a you know u.s
election
uh and if trump's got concerns about the
way it was done uh it's for him to
consider if there are legal options
we're not going to interfere and that is
not our job team
you have to concede though it it doesn't
look great and i understand
that you perhaps won't go as far as as
your colleague sergey javid
but you know his claim that this is
adolescent behavior does seem to have a
point
well look i'm not a returning officer in
the u.s election i don't know exactly
what uh
happened there if there were issues and
obviously those engaged in that election
i've got a right to look at that and
take that up but of the prime minister
has already
um you know welcomed joe biden to the
post issued a statement as of leaders
around the world
it does uh look pretty clear that joe
biden's won this election now he's
crossed that
uh threshold of 270 electoral college
votes and uh and you know appears to be
the next
u.s president we move on to potential
problems that we might have with with
our biden administration in a second but
there does appear to be something of an
opportunity an opening particularly for
your department with joe biden really
pushing on this
this green new deal and and we here in
the uk trying to
reposition ourselves as a leader in
green tech yes i mean obviously it'll be
a different administration with a
different focus in many areas but
i think it's fair to say on the
environmental front the
biden uh you know biden camp have been
quite clear that they're going to rejoin
the paris cop agreement and uh take a
leading role in tackling climate change
and i think that's a really
important opportunity for us we're
hosting cop 26
next october in the uk a big year on
biodiversity as well next year and i
think that this administration has
already signaled it's going to be
much more engaged in some of those
international forums for the environment
almost
almost feels like you're suggesting that
us leadership on environmental issues
has been missing for a few years
well the trump administration took a a
particular view
and on these matters um you know it's no
secret that we're not enthusiastic about
multilateral global agreements on issues
like the environment indeed they
withdrew
from some of those conventions so they
had a very clear stance on that
the biden camper suggesting a very
different approach and i think that's
probably uh right and consistent with
what the uk wants to see on the
environment
let's talk about where there may well be
problems and it certainly seems to be
the case joe biden has made it very
clear that he will not accept any
undermining of the good friday agreement
we know
uh that the internal markets bill is
going through the lords today
if various clauses are taken out by the
lords
will the government reinstate them
straight away well
and we will because the the uk internal
markets bill it's not about undermining
the belfast agreement it's about
standing behind it
uh and making sure that it works and
looking after um you know the interests
of northern ireland
making sure that the peace and stability
that's been uh hard won there can carry
on
and so the limited number of areas where
um we took a power subject to parliament
agreeing it
to be able to create legal clarity and
legal certainty should there be areas
that the joint committee process in the
uh negotiations with the eu if there are
areas they can't agree we've got to
provide that legal
certainty and legal clarity and that's
all the the bill does
in terms of the of the deal being struck
with the european union exactly where
are we and
and how much are we now apparently given
words that we heard from the government
over the weekend willing to concede on
the matter of fishing
uh well look the negotiations be going
on now for obviously many many months
they resume again this week i understand
there are still
differences there are still some
obstacles to overcome
but i think there's now you know some
good will on both sides to try to
progress things a lot of work going into
to that um
david frost and the negotiating team for
the uk working very hard to try to get
an agreement
and on fisheries and we've always um
we've always been open to doing a
a sensible approach um looking
potentially
at uh agreements that might span a
couple or three years for instance
um we're going to be sensible in how we
approach this but
making sure that we have control of our
own waters again and control access to
our waters has always been
a red line for us in these negotiations
it doesn't feel though that you're
steering way away from the idea that we
may well
be prepared to give ground on what what
to me has throughout this appeared like
a fairly obvious red line
our waters are a fish well we're not
giving ground on that i mean when you
leave the european union you do become
an independent coastal state you control
access
in your exclusive economic zone that's
out to 200 miles or the halfway point
that's what norway and pharaoh's and
every other country in the world
actually has it's just a
simple feature of international law so
that's a point of international law
rather than a matter for negotiation the
issue will become
how much uh what are the sharing
arrangements how much mutual access do
we allow in one another's waters
and that's obviously a discussion
that'll happen annually uh but there may
also be
you know a partnership agreement that
sets out the ground rules as to how we
will
work on that and we've certainly
published that and put proposals to the
eu
on your brief minister to two topics
that i never thought would uh coexist in
the one place
coveted 19 and danish minx tell us
exactly what is going on at the moment
because there is a mass cull ongoing in
denmark we have seen
uh essentially the walls being put up
between transport between there and here
is
is there anything that we need to be
concerned about well look
we don't have uh mink farming in this
country was banned
in 2002 and rightly so but some
countries in the world including in the
us
but also denmark and the netherlands as
well
do still allow mink farming and we know
that um
mink come from a family of animals the
mustelids that are
quite susceptible to covid19 uh indeed
so much so that they're sometimes used
for
uh you know experiments in this area to
understand the virus
and there has been a new strain that has
emerged in denmark and we think may also
be in the
uh netherlands as well but certainly
clear in the denmark
was it wise then for the for the the
travel ban to be announced that you know
half past one in the morning and brought
in at half past three it does always
feel
the the government's characterization of
this as a whack-a-mole strategy
sometimes is absolutely on the mark well
i think look we're responding
to um you know evolving evidence and
emerging events this is a
fast-moving virus um you know what we
realized at the end of
uh you know last week is that there had
been a new strain of the virus that had
developed in denmark and crucially
uh that had then reinfected a human from
a mink
that was a significant new development
and we felt it was important to
act expeditiously and quickly to uh to
try to
make sure there wasn't a risk of that
coming to the uk and that's all we've
done
could we talk briefly about about kate
bingham and her role um
on the coveted task force 670 thousand
pounds of taxpayers money
has been signed off for use on a team of
eight pr consultants
eight pr consultants who could have each
pointed out that spending 675 grand on
pr consultants
might not be the best idea what is going
on with ms bingham at the moment
well look i'm not involved then
obviously matt hancock
is in the department for health will be
monitoring
all of the work that they do um i don't
know whether it was strictly pr
consulted or whether it was management
consultants more generally
uh as you know neil i used to uh work in
uh
in that industry but also as preceptor
david cameron and so
you know generally i think these
resources can come from in-house but i
don't know the specific circumstances
of those particular contracts but as you
say your political antenna must surely
have been vibrating when you read about
that
in much the same way as when you read
about marcus rashford and his
campaign to to bring back free school
news just explain this one to me or
particularly on the marcus rashford
point
why did the government expend so much
political capital
on a battle that they were clearly never
going to win
on the one hand in one corner you've got
boris johnson in the other
you've got marcus rashford and poor
hungry children now you may well argue
that there is a point to be made a
debate to be had about provision outside
of term time
but the time to have that debate is
surely not in the middle of a viral
pandemic well look what we said at the
time and indeed i think last time i was
on this program
i i explained that the government didn't
think that the free school meals voucher
scheme was the right way to go because
that should be offered in term time
but there were other areas that were
under review and we we mentioned for
instance
the 63 million fund that we had for
local authorities uh we mentioned that
we were open to
uh extending that and increasing that
and looking at other ways of tackling
this problem and that's what we've
got you and your colleagues we're out in
front of the cameras you know this we're
opening the cameras
defending a decision that you probably
all expected was going to
if not a u-turn performed on it because
the the scheme that has been announced
is different to
to what has happened before but it would
look
pretty much like a u-turn well things
can be presented that way but i know and
i was involved in the discussion at the
time that
a decision was made by government the
free school meals wasn't the right way
to go but there were other things that
we could and should do in this space
those have been worked on and developed
and have been announced over the weekend
so
this is actually not a u-turn it's a
consistent approach
consistent with what we said at the time
that there were other ways that we ought
to intervene to help those in food
poverty and that's what we've done
and it's a scheme that will last all the
way till the end of next year
what about the year after that well um
look you take one year at a time on some
of these things but
um and these are obviously you know we
we refine things based on how they work
but the winter grant fund runs until
march
provides 170 million pounds to local
authorities
and then from next spring during the
easter summer and christmas holidays
next year
there's going to be increased funding
for the holiday
activities and food scheme which is all
about
supporting young people during those
holiday times run
by local authorities are very much
focused on getting to people to
understand food change the culture of
people's relationship with food
and to prepare food george used this
always good to see you thanks for
joining us thank you very much